Elizabeth has fallen in love with a new
character in Hope Valley straight away
and that is her baby do you think it's a
boy or a girl we'll find out soon enough
I know that Elizabeth is having a boy oh
my goodness
my little son big blue eyes and a little
man face and his little baby body and
just really sweet precious yeah I know I
just went to call him yes if we had any
doubt
[Music]
Jack how did you feel about this
storyline being introduced oh I am so
excited for Elizabeth top of buv
I feel like we were in a really sad low
spot for a minute there and it was hard
for all of us as a cast and crew but I
know it was very surprising and and sad
for the Hardys and so I think this is
gonna be a special gift to them to get
to see Jack's legacy live on through
this little Davey and I just love coming
to work with babies because do you first
cute I imagine it would be wonderful but
you can't know until you're actually
holding your baby the love affair that
Elizabeth has with her new baby is so
moving and so heartwarming and so heart
melting that I think the fans will find
joy in that and even though the Jack
character is now gone the new love in
her life and the love affair that she's
having with this baby is so uplifting I
think it's a great choice for the show
because the children in the school house
worked so well for one cause daughter
I'm so great you know it's like another
chapter on top of the Romantic chapter
on top of the town chapter and I think
they have a baby now it was just a new
chapter in this room you know big book
of one calls dog I remember when I read
that at the end at the end of last
season yeah that that was my you know I
could my throw got really tight and I
was like it was such a big moment we get
a little piece of Jack in town and it
was really important I think to carry
his spirit on it's really fun I think
it's great for her it's it opens up this
whole other side of her character and it
really I think pays a lot of homage to
the character of Jack as well because
it's a reflection of Hammond
it's an extension of him and I think
that it is a great thing that they're
doing it I just think it's so fun gets
twins that play her baby and whenever
they are on set like everyone behind the
camera and in front of the camera
everybody's just like like just yes like
they're like little beacons of light and
you just like everyone's following them
around like why don't they kind of tune
now playing a mom on screen you don't
have children in real life no have you
gone to Laurie or Jack or any of the
other cast mates about you know how to
approach this or you just kind of rely
on those gut instincts you know perhaps
I should have but I haven't really been
asking for advice or anything I've
worked a lot with babies and kids I
guess it comes pretty naturally then
again I'm not having to change the
diapers and wake up at 3:00 a.m. someone
who has experience working with twin
babies on us yeah yeah are you giving
Erin any advice she's just like a duck
to water with children geez I didn't
even see you in the in the school room
in the classroom how she's good with
general actors on the show and she just
has a bond with these twin babies that
you know are she doesn't need any advice
from me this is what you learn off
cameras like they go oh you should see
this the other day I go what the baby
all of a sudden he just kind of turned
just like its head fell right into
Erin's cheek and it just laid there so
you get these little quips you know
after things are already shot so I think
there's been some pretty magical baby
moments already what kind of mother is
Elizabeth Oh phenomenal like she's so
but she has her own dilemma this season
of being a single mom and having to go
back to work
town the community it takes a village
mentality comes in to her rescue which
is always lovely to see I mean I can't
even bring myself to separate the baby's
room
tourists thought I'd be doing it with
Jack not having him here it's just
overwhelming are we gonna hear
references to Mountie Jack we do here
Elizabeth speak of Jack and what life is
like without him and how her child
represents you know part of him now and
a part of her but he's his own special
little guy Dan was such an important
presence in our show for five years that
doesn't just disappear and I think it's
certainly really important to me that we
continue to honor that I promise that
your daddy is here watching over us he
always will
bill does several things that he has to
complete because that was Jack's work
right and it's you know it's he risked
his life for it and Elizabeth knows it
so I think it's a testament to honoring
that character to honoring the audience
to being true to this show but also to
be able to say life happens and this is
how we move on life goes on as much as
we suffer tragedy life goes on we're not
trying to be morning or maudlin or mired
down in the death of Jack but more in
the celebration of his life and what his
life brought to Elizabeth's life which
is this new life this new baby
[Music]
you